[Música]
el presidente francés emmanuel macon
aseguró que quiere fastidiar a quienes
no se han vacunado contra el joven 19
las declaraciones ocurren cuando francia
pasa por un incremento de nuevos
contagios por la variante omicron y
luego de que el debate sobre el paseo
vacunal quedará suspendido nuevamente en
la asamblea nacional
eeuu también atraviesa un repunte de
contagios por omicron durante la última
semana de diciembre un promedio de casi
400 menores de 17 años fueron
hospitalizados a diario mientras el
presidente joe biden advirtió que los no
vacunados corren un grave riesgo de
desarrollar síntomas severos analizamos
en esta emisión
el presidente de kazajistán despidió a
su gabinete para terminar con la ola de
protestas sin precedentes generadas por
el aumento del precio del combustible
miles de manifestantes asaltaron hoy la
sede del gobierno
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torre sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos esta emisión de noticias en
francia que registró un nuevo récord de
nuevos contagios de kobe 19 con más de
271 mil en medio del repunte del
gobierno busca incentivar a vacunarse a
los 5 millones de ciudadanos que aún no
lo han hecho mientras que la asamblea
nacional vuelve a suspender el debate
sobre el proyecto de ley para convertir
el pase sanitario en vacunar el
presidente macrón aseguró en una
entrevista con el diario le parisien que
quiere fastidiar a los no vacunados
pegándoles el ingreso a espectáculos
lugares de ocio e incluso al transporte
público el jefe de estado también
confirmó su candidatura a las elecciones
de abril en una entre en esa entrevista
estas fueron sus palabras
queda una pequeña minoría refractaria
como se reduce se reduce perdón por
decirlo así fastidiando todavía más yo
no estoy a favor de fastidiar a los
franceses me quejo todo el día cuando la
administración lo hace pero bueno a los
no vacunados sí que tengo muchas ganas
de fastidiar los y vamos a seguir
haciéndolo hasta el final esa es la
estrategia el presidente de eeuu joe
biden también hizo un llamado de los no
vacunados y advirtió que las próximas
semanas serán complejas por la variante
omicron la hospitalización de niños y
adolescentes es otro de los temas que
preocupa a las autoridades
estadounidenses en estos momentos
durante la última semana de 2021
promedio de 400 menores de 17 años
fueron internados en centros de salud
por kobe 19 los expertos hacen un
llamado a vacunarlos para evitar la
sintomatología grave para analizar esta
información conectamos con xabier zandio
arenys jefe de infectología pediátrica y
director de investigación clínica del
hospital del niño de panamá bienvenido
france24 en principio era común escuchar
que los síntomas en menores eran leves
porque ha aumentado entonces el número
de niños adolescentes hospitalizados por
ccoo beat
bueno gracias por la entrevista y nos ha
aumentado en muchas partes del mundo
sobre todo por la circulación de la
variante o micro la variante omicron
evidentemente no es tan
susceptible al efecto de la una sobre
todo a las personas que no han tenido
una dosis de refuerzo y está básicamente
buscando a gente vulnerable y gente
vulnerable a gente no vacunada y dentro
de la gente no vacunada precisamente son
los niños así que se ha visto un aumento
importante de cáncer en niños incluso de
hospitalizaciones en eeuu reino unido y
eso lo vamos a tener en todos nuestros
países en la medida en que empecemos a
vacunar niños probablemente vamos a
poder superar también está este evento
bueno ya se ha probado que las vacunas
son efectivas en los menores pero
entonces cuáles son los temores de los
padres a estas inoculaciones
yo creo que el principal temor es
básicamente que a los niños usualmente
la enfermedad tiende a ser bastante leve
en comparación como adolescentes y
adultos y ellos se preguntan por que
vacunarlos si realmente la enfermedad es
bastante leve no y el mensaje
básicamente es la enfermedad es leve en
la mayoría de los casos pero siempre hay
casos en que no es no es leve y hemos
tenido una buena cantidad de niños
hospitalizados
hemos tenido muerte por el niño por kobe
y hemos tenido este síndrome
inflamatorio multisistémico que nadie
sabe a quién le va a dar en la población
pediátrica que precisamente se ve en la
edad escolar entre 5 y 11 años de edad y
que uno no puede predecir a quién le da
o a quien no le da no entonces esos son
argumentos básicamente para para vacunar
además si las vacunas han demostrado
seguridad en niños y los datos de la cbs
por ejemplo 9 niños 9 millones de niños
vacunados ya dos millones con dos dosis
y realmente los eventos el perfil de
seguridad es espectacular de las vacunas
menos de la vacuna de facer entonces no
hay razón realmente a negarse a la
vacunación de hecho nosotros en
pediatría hemos vacunado con la varicela
contra hepatitis y contra el rotavirus
que son enfermedades incluso más
benignas que el kobe de la población
infantil doctor sant llorenç a usted
muchísimas gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france24 en
otras noticias del estado de canadá
aceptó compensar los daños sufridos por
los niños de los pueblos indígenas del
país que primero fueron arrebatados de
sus familias y luego maltratados durante
generaciones los pactos de este acuerdo
histórico suman una compensación de más
de 31 millones de dólares
la decisión es histórica el martes las
autoridades canadienses anunciaron dos
acuerdos de compensación para los niños
indígenas arrebatados a sus familias
desde finales del siglo 19
al menos 150.000 de estos niños
indígenas fueron enviados a internados
financiados por el estado donde fueron
sometidos a todo tipo de abusos el
gobierno ha anunciado el equivalente a
31 mil millones de dólares
estadounidenses para esta compensación
la mitad para compensar a las víctimas
conocidas ya sus familias y la otra
mitad para reformar el sistema
canadiense
veces este es el mejor acuerdo de la
historia de canadá pero ninguna cantidad
de dinero puede revertir los daños
sufridos por los niños de los pueblos
originarios sin embargo las injusticias
históricas requieren reparaciones y
starcraft racing
tenemos un largo camino que recorrer
para abordar la pobreza en nuestras
naciones y ninguna cantidad de dinero
será nunca la adecuada ni de volver a la
infancia perdida pero hoy se trata de
reconocimiento de ser visto y escuchado
según varios estudios al menos 55 mil
niños de esa época podrían beneficiarse
de una indemnización muchos consideran
que los pueblos indígenas han sido
víctimas de un genocidio cultural en
canadá dado que uno de los objetivos de
estos crímenes racistas masivos era la
asimilación el borrado gradual de estas
culturas la decisión sobre esta
indemnización se produce casi 15 años
después de las primeras denuncias de
derechos humanos which de cuatro más de
mil manifestantes asaltaron e
incendiaron la sede del gobierno en
kazajistán en medio de la crisis que
vive el país la nación ha sido escenario
de multitudinarias movilizaciones en los
últimos días tras el alza de los precios
del gas licuado que es usado por la
mayoría de los ciudadanos para sus
vehículos y otra conflagración en la
sede de la fiscalía y al menos 30
vehículos quedaron calcinados en gran
parte del territorio se han cortado de
los servicios de internet y la telefonía
móvil ha sido limitada en medio de las
protestas el presidente aceptó la
dimisión del gabinete y
queridos compatriotas los exhortó una
vez más a ver la razón y no reaccionar
ante las provocaciones de adentro y de
afuera
y la euforia de los mítines y la
permisibilidad los llamados a atacar
espacios de oficinas de autoridades
civiles y militares son absolutamente
ilegales esto es un crimen seguido por
un castigo y otras noticias a ser
presidente de brasilia air bolsonaro
evoluciona favorablemente con el
tratamiento al que fue sometido por la
obstrucción médica que lo llevó al
hospital desde el lunes los médicos del
mandatario confirmaron que le fue
retirada la sonda nasogástrica luego de
que la oclusión intestinal fuera
disuelta no obstante aún no hay fecha
para darle el alta al jefe de estado
y la fiscalía peruana abrió una
investigación preliminar en contra del
presidente pedro castillo por presuntos
delitos de tráfico de influencias y
colusión en concreto se cuestiona que
dos grandes empresas ganaron
licitaciones luego de que supuestamente
el mandatario se reuniera con personas
vinculadas a esas compañías según un
reportaje periodístico uno de sus
presuntos encuentros se produjo fuera
del palacio de gobierno y sin ningún
registro oficial por un campesino
uno inicia el cese en las vegas la que
es considerada la feria de tecnología
más importante del mundo debido a la
pandemia del evento cuenta con un
formato híbrido que mezcla las
presentaciones presenciales y virtuales
algunos de los más destacados
expositores como amazon microsoft intel
google o meta no tendrán representación
personal sin embargo los responsables
destacaron que unas 2200 compañías se
reunirán en las vegas' el evento fue
recortado un día por el avance de
omicron y finalizará el 7 de enero
corea del sur y japón reportaron el
lanzamiento de un misil balístico por
parte de corea del norte durante la
mañana de este miércoles este es el
primer lanzamiento que realizan en más
de dos meses y ocurre una semana después
de que el líder norcoreano kim jong-un
prometiera impulsar aún más su capacidad
militar aunque no mencionó
específicamente sus misiles y armas
nucleares por las que ha recibido
sanciones internacionales
así concluimos esta emisión de noticias
a ustedes les agradecemos su sintonía
los invitamos a ampliar toda la
información en nuestra web france24
puntocom
[Música]